It's Jimmy Fallon.
(audience cheering)
What's going on?
Oh my god, I love you.
Wow, an audience.
This is fantastic.
The last time--
I mean there are people here.
They sound great, they're great, I love you guys.
I love you.
Wait the last time you were here
was there not an audience still?
It was, no, it was pre anything.
'Cause we've done the show a bunch of times
but I think, is this the first time--
First time back after--
With an audience.
Yes exactly right.
So his wife Nan and I started Flower Films,
our production company when I was 19.
So 28 years ago.
You dared my wife.
I dared your wife to start a production company.
And you guys knocked it outta the park.
And me and Chris Miller and Jimmy
and then we all met on Fever Pitch
and Nan and Jimmy fell in love and got married
and had two kids.
You were good luck.
You were very good luck for me.
I'm--
I'm loving this show by the way, it's crushing.
Everyone's good, Ross, I don't see him,
but maybe he's hiding.
Rossy.
He's fantastic.
The show's great, it's what you want in the morning.
I want you, I want your sunshine, I want your energy.
Do you have like a ritual before you go out every night?
What goes through your mind before that curtain opens?
Can you bring us inside your head and your heart
or what is it before that curtain opens every night?
It butterflies, it's excitement.
You get a quick touch up of hair and makeup,
you make sure your suit is on.
Then they're like, you hear the roots are playing.
There's a curtain here and Higgins gets announced.
He comes in, it's like how many seconds?
20 seconds.
And the band's like 20 seconds, then it's quiet.
Then the band kicks in, you see the tile.
And then when I'm about to go out, it's it
the light hits the curtain.
You can see the circle and then it just fluffs out.
And you're like, all right.
And you go out and it's like going, starting a race
or going into the ring or something
where you're just like I don't know if these jokes
are funny.
This is the first time I'm reading them.
There was nothing on the page this morning.
My amazing writers wrote all of these jokes today.
Like as of this morning, there's no,
right now there's no monologue.
It gets done in the afternoon.
Well also, because you have to be current.
A lot of that monologue
for someone like me
You have to.
The viewer is also getting information and news.
I love that about opening monologues.
Not only are you getting comedy
but you are getting information
about what is going on in the world that day.
Yeah yeah you are.
You shouldn't, but yes you are.
Please read the news and whatever and go to better outlets.
But yes, I used to do that when I was a kid
with "Weekend Update" too.
That's how I'd find out what's going on in the world.
I go, I don't know what's going on in the world
but I know now through Dennis Miller.
I mean "Weekend Update" is such a big influence
on the Drew's News
'cause I grew up loving "Weekend Update".
And one of my favorite iterations obviously
is you and Tina Fey.
That's nice, yeah.
Come on.
She's the absolute greatest.
We had such a good chemistry.
It was like the kid who didn't do his homework
and the smart girl that's gonna give him the answers.
That's kind of how our chemistry was like.
And she was just so fun.
And I remember she would write these monologues for her,
she would write jokes for me all the time
but she wrote these monologues for her
that would just destroy.
I mean like wiping your tears and going like,
oh my gosh can we give an Emmy every episode to this person?
Tina Fey is a genius.
Can I ask you a personal question?
Yeah.
I think this book, cause I've read all of the books.
I have all the books.
We read all the books, me and my two daughters.
One of which is your wife's goddaughter.
Yeah.
It started out with "Dada."
Yeah, it did.
Yeah it took off
My baby's first words is dada.
My favorite "Mama".
Everything is mama.
Then "This Is Baby" was one where it's a baby body book.
Like where's your nose, where's your eyes
and stuff like that, it's cute.
And now it's "Nana".
Because nana loves you more
and you know why nana loves you more.
Why?
Billy Jay, that was his line.
If you said Nancy's father if you said
bye Billy Jay, I love you.
He would say, I love you more.
And I was like, wow, that's such a good line.
I wish it was mine.
And so yeah, I took from that.
I didn't know that.
Yeah, I love you more he always said,
and so I want grandmas and their grandkids
to get in the room, they get the parents outta there
and let's just go me and you,
let's make some memories and they go,
and basically the idea is like, what do you love?
And the grandma says, whatever it is you love
I love you more than that.
So you can think of anything in the world,
like chocolate, chocolate bar fountains.
And you're like, nah, I love you more than that.
I love you more than--
Wait hold on.
Which one?
Yeah, there's only 10 pages.
But they're all quality pages.
Will you read like two or three pages?
Oh my gosh.
Because I'm sorry, it's the most selling point
of the book, it's so good.
"More than the moon, more than the stars.
More than all of the planets by far.
More than Paris and the Eiffel Tower.
More than cats with super cat power."
Yes!
(everyone laughing)
It's weird.
I got to be really creative for this one.
It's so good.
You know what it is?
I got a little weepy with this one too.
'Cause I like books that are a little sad, but not too sad.
From, "Forever, from one past 104.
You'll always love nana, but nana loves you more."
Because even when nana's not around the love that you get
from a grandma, you never forget.
And if you're lucky to get it, it's the coolest.
Yeah, you'll never forget it.
Yeah.
(upbeat music)